Oh
you know I when I was at the paper I
would met my assistant Arthur bovino a
very good journalist he and I would we
had a game we would both read the paper
before we came to work and we would bet
on what was the mail going to be about
what were people to be complaining about
and of course within a couple months we
knew exactly what people would be
complaining about we learned how the
average x reader or not even the average
time sort of the times readers in
general responded to the newspaper so I
began to respond that way and I would
see things that would irritate me that I
might not have noticed at an earlier
time I tried to stop doing that when I
left the paper and I've been pretty good
about it the only time that I really
wanted to go and grab somebody around
the neck was the Duke Lacrosse case and
I'm happy to say that I'm proud to say I
gave a speech to the Nieman Journalism
fellows and at Harvard while that was
breaking barrier within the first month
and I said this is going to be a
catastrophe this journalism it's not
good journalism and this is something
where a story is being blown up to much
larger scale than it deserves to be
because it fits so many preconceptions
of so many of the editors at The Times
you know it was white / black it was
rich / pora was educated over an
educated it was male / female aha let's
go do something about this and because
the times did it that led to everybody
else doing it so Newsweek does a cover
story that never would have happened had
let the time has been putting it on the
front page for several day so that was
driving me crazy on the other hand it
wasn't my job any longer to be the cop
so I left that to my successor
well the biggest problems confronting
the time specifically are the same
problems as providing it confronting
everybody in the news business which is
the people don't seem to be willing to
pay for their news or let me turn that
around i think the times seems very
reluctant to charge people for the news
although they have announced that
they're going to begin charging online
in too early 2011 I still sense of
trepidation and I wish it were otherwise
I wish they had more confidence i think
that it may be hard for this regional
paper or that metropolitan paper or this
small-town paper to charge for news but
i think the times can get away with it
because it is the for a large portion of
the educated populace it is the
authoritative voice what's happening in
the world you know there are something
like i don't know how many tens of it i
think it's a now over 10 million people
let me state that you know there are
millions of people who go to that
website every day all over the world now
if he started charging ten dollars a
month with a lot of them stop yes with
all of them stopped no would fifty
percent stop i don't know but i did the
math not long ago and i think that if
twenty percent of them stayed that would
cover the cost of the newsroom and what
the people in news business seem
reluctant to realize is that's the only
thing that matters that that it's the
production of news being rewarded with
revenue to cover the cost and perhaps
producer profit that's what counts the
making of a newspaper isn't what counts
and I think you know if somebody had
gone to the newspaper publishers and
magazine publishers of America 20 years
ago and said I have a new business model
for you no paper no ink no trucks no
Teamsters no Pressman no printers Union
no newsstands they'd say give it to me
tomorrow this is heaven we just want to
put our words and pictures out there but
they were so intent on protecting the
current revenue stream the money that
advertisers pay and the money that
individuals pay for the paper that they
didn't see that this was a boon for them
and they made the same mistake that
music business made and the music
business lost control of their industry
they lost control of it the steve jobs
because they wanted to continue to sell
cds from fifteen dollars
and I think that the same thing is
happening in the print business I'm glad
to see that the times is moving and I
think once the times moves many other
institutions will move as well charge
people for your product if they're not
willing to pay for it maybe you've got a
problem with your product